welcome back to glamour unfiltered your
celebrity franchise what we get to the
heart some of the issues that mean the
most of the world's most inspiring
celebrities and today we are joined by
the new queen of Netflix and Hollywood's
new Beauty star Lucy pointers I mean the
politician is amazing come to Netflix at
the end of September sent your Diaries
how to help people we hate Peyton way
more than you do I should kill her
it really does some really amazing
issues so it deals with depression
suicide it deals with gender jealous
with sexuality it does all these amazing
things that we are all going for is like
young people today what kind of
relationship you have with your own
mental health would you say I think it's
an interesting thing that has only
really started to be a conversation
later in my mind I don't really remember
at high school it being much of a topic
of conversation I know that we could go
to the school nurses to discuss anything
if we wanted to but it wasn't a thing
that was done ever
and I imagine now I don't know I guess
with social media where it's much it's
become much more common to talk about it
openly and share because how do you look
after in that sense like what do you do
to check in on yourselves stay away from
social media yeah that one is it that's
the killer and I know everyone says it
yeah then it hits you it's like oh right
that's why everyone says it it's bad
mm-hmm because obviously I feel like the
social media thing it's just like hum if
it's not keeper on me right like you I
mean like leave it out like if it's not
working for you it's not working for you
and I think I mean it's hard it's always
that conversation I think it has so many
pros and cons but I think yeah as soon
as it starts to feel
negative it's a hard thing to put away I
think for a lot of people that's why
they find that community as well
what's your person journey been like
we're finding your own voice I think I
find it easy to lean into being more shy
and kind of apologetic myself and that's
where Astrid came in very handy because
she kind of she's so unapologetic and
I'm so happy for opinion to be heard and
to take up space that I would walk away
from playing her for a week and my voice
would be a little bit louder and I would
take up a bit more space and feel a bit
more confident and realized how much I
had not been doing that in my own time
what was it like going back to school
years to film this obviously our
schooling system in the UK is wildly
different today's be different but what
was it like putting yourself back in
that position a few I think it made the
job more interesting and somewhat easier
because I think if you're trying to say
something about the period you are
currently in it's harder to have any
perspective whereas being on the outside
of that it was yea really interesting to
go back and I think you can go back with
a better insight and then you've got to
walk away today and not being high
school yeah what was it like what was
high school ITA a really good education
really interesting classes and teachers
but it was a little of school so it was
creepy as hell yeah given me a thicker
skin mmm
Astrid is obviously kind of like the
popular gal around town yeah what was
your own relationship with popular team
when you're growing up I think it's such
a stressful thing for as long as you put
any weight on it and alway I think
you're always aware especially all those
of a kind of hierarchy mmm
and so I always remember being aware of
who the popular girls were and then kind
of being okay with staying outside of
that I think this job helped me a lot as
well because I always had another world
to go to so school was never everything
for me and so I guess that's how I kind
of survived exits and this isn't the
biggest thing in the world and I can
walk away and feel sane elsewhere and
know that this is a smaller scale
because also you've been walking since
you were 12 years old right like you've
been working 9 to 5 for a while
sometimes because I think a lot of
people look at this and be like oh my
god you've had the most amazing year and
you can like pass out nowhere
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding ten years later
in that time because I guess there must
be so many ups and downs
what is would you say has been the down
you've learned the most from and the up
you've learned the most from when I was
14 I've been working somewhat steadily
for a few years which is a crazy thing
to say 14 year old but then I had to
take a break to do GCSEs and do my exams
and everything and I didn't really mind
at the time I was kind of excited to go
back doesn't miss out on all my friends
birthdays and stuff and then I kind of
thought I could pick up where I left off
when I saw it again and it was a shock
to realize I couldn't I was
obviously a very different costing
bracket when I went back I was like 17
18 I got to have my awkward phase
off-camera then yes but I think I
learned a lot from that period because
it forced me to really question why I
needed it whether I did need it and how
hard I had to work for it and if that
was worth it and it took a few years of
a hell of a lot of rejection I mean
doing auditions several times a week few
years and not getting anything and just
like powering through that and finding
inspiration or excitement in the
auditions I was doing in that being
announced the rejection can actually
teach you so much right yes what do you
think it's taught you there is okay and
it's not a reflection always of you hmm
especially in work especially in this
job if everything just falls into your
lap you don't learn how to work hard you
don't learn any kind of work ethic but I
love that thing you said when you said
at school you felt like you were taught
and it was assumed that you would have
male bosses that women were taught they
were gonna have male bosses it's just
that thing that in you instill in young
women at a young age if they don't wear
a short skirt because it's uncomfortable
for the male teachers you can't wear
bare shoulders because it's
uncomfortable for men and male teachers
well the boys school thinking you and
stuff rather than like how do you want
to feel how do you want to present as a
human being as a woman are you so
shocked by any auntie feminist things
what's been something that shocked you
recently would you say you've been like
well this conversation will have to have
this conversation yeah and also I mean I
was on a panel with Brit Marling at
Venice Film Festival reasons and she was
saying like as a person who is now a
creator a writer a director she is been
has been in the room where they discuss
a representation and
than need to get more women in the room
and she was saying that it's ridiculous
it's spoken about as if it's this very
difficult thing more women and it's just
how can we possibly do it just like it's
just not that hard that is space just do
it we've watched so many men's stories
for so long the idea that the only
stories women had to tell are in terms
of men or as the wife or girlfriend or
the repercussions of a man's narrative
is baffling do you feel more empowered
than ever before today sure yeah yes sir
I mean while we were filming this I was
doing promotion of the Bohemian Rhapsody
and we were talking so consistently
about the lessons that Freddie would
talk about in terms of identity and what
he hoped to inspire in people and then
I'd go to work on this and realize that
that was happening that the things that
we were representing in this show are
the things that he was unable to at the
time but being kind of would call so
it's repercussions to be able to do that
so it was really amazing to preach it in
the day yeah and actually activate yeah
but like you've been saying you've gone
through your own competence issues first
different times your life you come out
the other side you're the empower person
sat for a stay about to slay it again on
this Netflix show what advice would you
give to someone who was possibly out
there right now watching this who's
struggling with their own confidence
surround yourself by intellectually
stimulating people by people who make
you feel good and who you
make feel good such a waste of time to
try and conform in any way and like be a
sheep and all that I know that's it easy
to say not being in an old console
anymore but I wish I hadn't wasted so
much time trying to identify by other
people's standards and fit in and
conform to that what kind of stuff did
you feel like you were trying to fit
into what was cool and the rate with
which people the speed at which people
are growing up I think I was always very
young and everyone some of the girls in
my year I think we're growing up much
faster and you feel I think a younger
age being different isn't good thank you
it worries you and you you and me
realize when it's too late when you're
out of it that it was actually such a
great thing and it's probably the thing
that fuels you in a different way that
will get you where you're going but then
the comparison culture is there day in
day out in front of our eyes and it's
also then on social media as well I
don't know how you step away from it but
step away from it yeah another thing
it's like I didn't have to grow up with
all of that you could go home and if
someone wanted to like pick up by with
you they'd have to call your home phone
and go through your mom fire but there
is now it's all just like right here and
these things that are so that become all
world
hmm be that cool person at social media
be that cool person and watch the
politician and that will also empower
you as well thank you so much baby
you're the main thing I'm thinking of
even more empowered than sitting here
with you asteroid energy that's really
the asteroid energy yeah be more Astrid
yeah don't tiptoe around people don't do
anything for more empowering videos like
this such an empowering people
as Lisa Bloomington exhibit a make sure
you subscribe to the glamour UK channels
now and we see you in two weeks for the
next episode of glamour unfiltered with
me Josh
you
[Music]